[Musique]
le Conseil constitutionnel proclame élu
président de la République quand le
Conseil consuel a été créé il prenait 5
décisions par an donner de la substance
à ses droits constitutionnels
aujourd'hui le Conseil constitutionnel
prend sans décision par an ça donne
toute sa place à l'état de droit le
Conseil constitutionnel mode d'emploi la
gomme le crayon et le citoyen épisode 3
je dois
professeur de droit et membre du Conseil
nommé par Valéry Giscard d'Estaing en
1980 avait trouvé une maxime pour
définir la marge de manœuvre du Conseil
constitutionnel je cite le conseil à
droit à l'égard des textes qui lui sont
déférés à utiliser la gomme
[Musique]
autrement dit le conseil ne refait pas
les lois mais il peut dans certains cas
gommer toute partie d'une loi à
condition qu'il soit saisie mais c'est
si par
qui avant 1974 seul pouvait d'où saisir
le président de la République le Premier
ministre le président du Sénat le
président de l'Assemblée et en 1974
monsieur Giscard d'Estaing a pu voter à
une réforme très importante disant non
c'est pas simplement ces quatre
autorités qui peuvent saisir le Conseil
mais ce sont au moins 60 débutés ou 60
sénateurs désormais les oppositions
peuvent saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est beaucoup plus
démocratique l'opposition ne peut pas se
contenter de contester un texte pour des
motifs politiques il faut trouver des
arguments juridiques et des arguments
constitutionnels ça a contribué on le
dit moins mais à ce que les
parlementaires s'approprient davantage
le texte de la Constitution mais
l'évolution des modalités de saisine du
Conseil ne s'arrêtent pas là en 2010 la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité la QPC fait son
entrée une idée semée par Robert
Badinter 20 ans plus tôt alors président
ce que l'on peut donner aux Français
c'est le droit à ce prévaloir
individuellement de la Déclaration des
droits quand ils sont jugés ils peuvent
dire non la loi est à constitutionnelle
et donc le Conseil constitutionnel du
coup au lieu de prendre comme au début 5
décisions ou comme après la réforme
ouvrant au parlementaire 15 ou 20
décisions prend sans décision par an
applicable à toutes les lois et à tous
les domaines les QPC mettent plus
directement en relation la Constitution
avec des branches du droit et donc parmi
les membres du service juridique du
Conseil constitutionnel il y a une
attention qui est portée au fait d'avoir
de très fins connaisseurs de la
procédure pénale des procédures fiscales
tout droit de la famille bref toutes les
branches du droit qui peuvent être au
point de départ d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité le
conseil n'est donc pas à contre-pouvoir
mais bel et bien un organe suprême de
contrôle de l'État de droit il peut être
saisi par le pouvoir exécutif le pouvoir
législatif et depuis 2010 les
justiciables sont aussi à l'initiative
du contrôle avec la QPC
[Musique]